hi I'm Adrian cruller I'm a clinical
psychologist in Los Angeles I've been
working with kids and families for about
10 years I am a licensed psychologist
working with children ages 3 to 18 I
started working with children when I did
a master's in art therapy I really loved
working with families to help them
understand their kids better communicate
better and get along better with their
friends and family so some of those
signs of depression in children might be
not wanting to do things that they
normally like to do like they don't want
to go to their normal soccer practice
they might not want to go to a sleepover
and they normally would really like that
another thing that kids might show when
they're feeling depressed is some bodily
symptoms they might have headaches more
often maybe more stomachaches they might
go to the nurse's office more often they
might also have trouble getting along
with other kids at school or with their
siblings
you might hear about this at a school
meeting kids might also be a little more
irritable maybe they have more outbursts
you might notice that they're a little
more angry than they normally would be
that would definitely be a sign that
they're having some sort of sadness
going on when talking with your kids
about their feelings it is really
important to let them know that you are
safe to talk to that you can be there
for them it's when they're feeling sad
might not understand that they feel
depressed they may not know what's
really going on to them so it's really
important as adults that we provide a
really safe space for them to talk we
might want to give them a lot of
reassurance and provide them some
encouragement to open up if you do have
concerns that your child is in danger or
they may have thoughts of hurting
themselves or someone else it is
important to reach out for help right
away
don't wait you can call your local
emergency services 911 or the suicide
hotline they do have a youth division
any attention to feelings is really
important to understand how we are
getting along in the world with
ourselves and with other people reaching
out to a professional can be a great way
to just start the conversation kids can
make a lot of progress in therapy they
can really start to understand who they
are as people even when they're very
little so it's nice for them to have a
space
for they can't get to know themselves
start to understand how they want to be
in the world
[Music]
you